So let's go to Logan from San Jose, California.
Logan, you're on the air.
Hi, can you hear me all right?
Yes, I can.
Thanks, David.
I'm also from the Bay Area, so I'll I'll make
up for the last person.
Beautiful.
My question is on the Joe Biden's covid relief
bill.
Yes, I noticed there was the 15 dollar minimum
wage that in there.
I'm kind of wondering the purpose of that
because it doesn't seem like now's the right
time with small businesses already looking
to make payroll or not being able to make
payroll.
And it seems like it's only going to slow
down a time-sensitive, Bill.
You know, I didn't see that.
Let me see.
Let's see here.
Biden stem.
I didn't know that that was part of Biden's
stimulus.
Let me take a look.
I'm pulling up an article about that.
Biden called for a rescue package of one point
nine trillion.
And we have all of the things increasing the
federal minimum wage to 15 dollars per hour.
Oh, that's interesting.
You know, it's not it's not clear to me that
he's calling for that to be in the bill.
And quite frankly, I don't even know if you
can do it that way, but I'd have to look into
that more.
That's it's an interesting question.
I didn't think I thought he was saying part
of my economic plan is a 15 dollar minimum
wage.
I didn't think he wanted that literally in
the covid rescue bill.
OK, you know, I admittedly didn't look too
closely at it, I thought it was a part of
it, but I'm not 100 percent sure.
Right.
I know it was part of his presentation, but
that's a really good question.
Whether you would include a minimum wage change
in the bill.
And listen, let me put it this way.
Even if he is thinking of putting a minimum
wage of fifteen dollars in the covid relief
bill, that's going to be negotiated out.
It's not going to get passed as part of covid
relief that I can assure you.
Got it.
One other quick question.
I noticed today in the inaugural address and
Joe Biden has been really pushing for unity,
reaching across the aisle in between parties.
I'm wondering what that is going to look like
in your opinion.
Oh, it's a complete impossibility.
I mean, I think it's great that Joe Biden
is using this language.
And to the extent that it will appeal to voters
to hear Joe Biden say, even after all this,
I'm everybody's president, I think that's
great.
How are you going to have unity with Mitch
McConnell, Lauren Bobert, Marjorie Taylor
Green?
You know, there's just no way.
There's no it's just not going to happen.
But I think Biden's doing the right thing
by saying it, because until they show him,
they will be obstructionists.
Biden should go forward saying, let's work
together and then we'll see what happens.
Yeah, that's thought I wasn't sure how it
was possible.
Yeah, no, it's not.
It's not.
But it's good for Biden to say it.
All right, that's
all I got for
you today, David, thanks.
All right, thanks very much.
Appreciate it.